lock down lcks lights out of sight this
is a
drill drills like this where kids
practice what they would do if a gunman
attacked their school are part of life
for most students in
America if we do just like one wrong
move then we can be like
goners but there are now efforts to try
to limit drills because of fears they
may be doing more harm than good when
the lights go off I just feel
scared so what's the truth about
lockdowns the total of 15 people are
believed to have died here 12 students
one faculty member and the two young
Killers drills teaching children how to
avoid an active shooter became
widespread after the mass shooting at
Coline High High School in
1999 on that day gunmen roamed the halls
for nearly an hour but people who hid in
locked rooms
survived since then kids have been
practicing how best to keep out of a
Gunman's line of
sight it is concerning that this is the
point that we're at but the biggest
thing is apparent is you want to be able
to have that peace of mind that the
school is going to do everything they
possibly can to keep your kids
safe but there are no National
guidelines about how many drills schools
should run in New York schools are
required to run four a year while
Michigan only requires
one and it's then down to individual
districts or even schools how to do them
some active shooter drills have been so
realistic students messaged their
parents saying they thought they were
going to
die a study by Georgia Tech and gun
control Lobby group every town found
language indicating depression and
anxiety increased on social media
following
drills this has led to calls to limit
drills or stop them
altogether a bill is being considered in
New York for example which would limit
drills to one per year in some places
rather than limiting drills researchers
are trying to work out how to make them
less upsetting we don't set schools on
fire to practice a fire drill so it's
really important that we're not
simulating active shooter events to
practice a
lockdown researchers here in Syracuse
have been observing students reactions
to drills for 5 years and found they
helped them feel more prepared for
emergencies great job drill be over
soon if I'm just sitting there being
quiet I'm thinking to myself like what
could happen because if it did happen I
think it would be um really
scary although there is evidence hiding
behind a locked door saves lives it is
very unlikely a child will be involved
in a Coline style
Siege so more research is needed into
how best to balance preparing for the
worst with reducing the distress caused
by drills do you think that the the
drills are a good idea you think it's
good to do them yeah I think it's very
good to do them because again it like
get you prepared for the stuff that
might
happen thank you for watching to read
more about gun violence in schools click
the link and don't forget to
[Music]
subscribe